California has just passed a really
important bill to make prostitution much
much easier so this is a bill it was it
was signed into law by governor baitman
Patrick baitman of of gomorah by the sea
but the bill was authored by none other
than Democrat state senator Scott weiner
uh Senator
weiner is aptly named of course and
because all nature is but art unknown to
the all chance Direction which th can
not see in Providence Winks uh
frequently Senator weiner is best known
for authoring legislation that reduced
crimes for pasts so for grown homosexual
men who uh would engage in statutory
rape and molestation with with young
teenage boys uh he he wanted to reduce
the penalties for for those men so
that's kind of what he's known for tells
you a lot about his political views and
agenda uh so now he's got a new bill out
which uh decriminalizes loitering with
intent to commit
prostitution which doesn't seem like a
huge deal except that it effectively
legalizes prostitution in California
because the way that law enforcement
stops prostitution is by driving around
seeing the hookers standing around on
the
corner they're not hard to spot and so
they they pull up and then if they can
get them on loitering with intent to
commit prostitution they can suppress
the vice and it's a lot easier to
prosecute a lot of Californians hate
this national city mayor Ron Morrison uh
who is an independent politically he
criticized the law and said that the
prostitutes are now wearing less than
you would consider a scanty negl they're
flaunting in everybody's face and you
can see it the the video clips they're
wearing dental
floss my question
is
why why I get why Senator weiner wants
wants to do this because he's a pervert
and a weirdo but why is anyone
tolerating this why did Governor baitman
who thinks that he's going to run for
president why why did he sign it into
law why are there liberals who are
normal people who are not perverts who
are not weirdos not that weird I guess
why are they going along with this why
do people feel obligated to tolerate
things that universally make life worse
prostitution doesn't make life better
for any body doesn't make life better
for the hookers doesn't make life better
for the Johns doesn't make life better
for the neighborhoods doesn't make life
better for the kids who are going to see
this stuff on the street corners and be
scandalized doesn't make life doesn't
make life better for anybody so why do
we tolerate that right now text nolles
to 9898 98 the G20 the group of 20 is an
international forum for governments and
Central Bank Governors it was
established in response to the financial
crisis of the late 1990s with the aim of
promoting International Financial
stability last month the G20 announced a
plan to impose digital currencies and
digital IDs on their respective
populations Central Bank digital
currencies essentially allow the
government to track every purchase that
you make even if you don't follow
International economic policies all that
closely you should be concerned and you
should consider diversifying at least
some of your assets into physical gold
with the help of Birch gold group call
Birch gold today to preserve your
savings in a tax sheltered retirement
account if you have an IRA or 401K from
a previous employer called Birch gold
they will help you convert it into an
IRA in Gold you will not pay a penny out
of pocket they will simply convert that
401k that would otherwise be sitting in
a bank somewhere into physical gold
which cannot be tampered with text
nolles kwes to 98
9898 Birch gold will send you a free
info kit on gold if digital currency
becomes a reality you will be glad that
you have something physical to fall back
on text nolles to 98 9898 and claim your
free info kit on gold today right now go
to Med
share.com as a dailywire subscriber you
are not just informed you are engaged
and you're handsome too you value
freedom and responsibility that is why
you got to check out Medishare Medishare
is a community-based approach to
healthcare that lines up with the
principles that you believe in your
values matter and with Medishare your
Healthcare dollars will not be used for
medical procedures that don't line up
with your beliefs Medishare is the
highest rated Healthcare sharing
Ministry with a 30-year proven track
record it's not health insurance it's a
community of 400,000 believers committed
to caring and sharing with one another
members save up to 50% or more on their
monthly healthcare costs and member
satisfaction surveys show that they like
Meda share much more than health
insurance why because it works for a
limited time dailywire listeners will
receive a $150 gift card when they join
metashare to find out more go to
medishare.com Michel Mi I AEL that is
medishare.com m i AEL terms and
conditions apply
because we're
told it that's
Liberty because we're told that's
Freedom it's not freedom I mean I've
talked about the distinction between
Liberty and license so many times I'm
not going to rehearse it now that's not
true freedom freedom isn't just a
neutrality in the face of Good and Evil
right and wrong true and
false true freedom is dependent upon a
perfect will and a perfect will is
dependent on perfect understanding and
this is why the truth will set you free
and vice and lies and delusion will make
you a slave but even putting all of that
aside if we all know that this thing
makes life worse then why would an
argument even from this ridiculous
definition misde of Liberty why would
that be persuasive aren't we putting the
cart before the horse there what's the
point of Liberty it says right in the
Constitution what the point of Liberty
is which is that our framers of our
constitution the founding fathers of our
country
they wanted to establish a political
order that would ensure the blessings of
liberty we hear this all the
time but the phrase blessings of liberty
implies that Liberty is not an end unto
itself that Liberty is a means to an end
that Liberty is
instrumental the Constitution doesn't
say we we establish this framework to
secure Liberty is it the blessings of
liberty because of course Liberty is not
the end the end of
society just the end of our society the
end of all political societies is the
good life a good nice place to
live that's what it's always about the
the fundamental rule of politics is do
good and avoid evil happens to be the
fundamental rule in our personal lives
too why do it if if your
ideology is forcing you to come to
political conclusions that make life
worse for everybody whether we're
talking about hookers in California
whether we're talking about Mass
migration of people who are usually
mobbed up with the cartels and who at
the very least are young fighting age
men who are economic migrants who are
drain on resources and who are not
assimilating I in any of these
issues if your ideology is leading you
to conclusions that harm everybody then
ditch your ideology you have a stupid
ideology and you should you should be
normal and sensible and reasonable and
and not not choose an abstract Theory
over the Practical realities that we all
know to be
true look at this kind of Liberty the
irony of this this view of Liberty of
course is that it always ends up looking
tyrannical after it's been implemented
for a little while you say we need we
need
tolerance okay and in the name of
Tolerance we're going to at everything
except for intolerance if you're
intolerant then we're going to ostracize
you and we're going to kill you and
we're going to arrest you and that would
be absolutely terrible boy what a great
clip that was
now ring that Bell subscribe to the
Michael nlls YouTube channel we'll see
you next time